So what I want to do is I want to explain something about cellulite now if you're sitting home right now
And you have cellulite. I'm just gonna tell you right now
Cellulite is a myth in other words
There's no difference between cellulite and other types of fat in the body unless it's in the belly, which is this real fat?
That's in around the organs, but cellulite is not really a specialized type of fat. What it is. It's not really
Fat at all it's really
atrophy of the muscle right underneath the skin in your skin you have all these in the cellulite you have all these dimply I
Guess it's like an orange peel effect where you have these jiggly types. You know thighs or hips
under right underneath that layer of superficial fat you have
Muscles that have not been toned properly. They're
Atrophy and atrophy is a shrinkage of the muscle because it's not activated
So one of the mistakes that people make is they go to the gym, and they do weight training and machines
That's what they do have the curves
That's what you do at the gym, and you really get nowhere because those are a two dimensional exercise
The secret to handling cellulite is to do
multi-dimensional workouts in other words in the lower part of your body you have
90 muscles so when you workout you need to activate all
90 so the best exercise for cellulite would be the exercise that would involve all
90 muscles and it's hard to come up with an exercise that will do that
So I'm gonna show you a really good routine for the gluttonous Maximus for example
We're just going to focus on that
To be able to tone that in three different ways and you would do this in every single workout. Okay, now. There's a program
I'll be releasing
in about a month or two that is
Going to involve the whole body, but in this
I'm just going to give you a little taste of what you're in for it's pretty cool, but in this these workouts
you're going to hit the
Atrophied muscle from three different ways so you're going to do 10 reps, okay?
You can do 3 sets of 10 reps so you're gonna do each exercise
three times
Okay, ten times through each repetition
So we'll do that and then you're gonna rest about one to two minutes between each set so it makes it a really good workout
all right and
Before I show you these exercises. I want to show you a picture of a lady who?
started working out when she was
56 years old she started she was the couch potato she never worked out a day in her life, okay, and she's
75 years old check this out, so
This lady is 75 years old so people really have no more excuses
And if you can look at that looked like that when you're 75 I mean
It's incredible, so here's a gal who has no cellulite. She works out she does
multi-dimensional workouts and
There's not one bit of fat on her body. I mean it's a very very small amount so
This whole age thing is overrated. It's not the age. It's basically
the knowledge of how to get your body back, okay, so
So stop the two-dimensional workouts do three-dimensional, and you want to work all 90 muscles. Hope you enjoy this check it out